[Music]
hi
this is paul muldoon and it's a
privilege to be with you
this afternoon or morning as it is for
me i'm
at the moment in new york state
this part of the world where i spend a
lot of my time
has quite a large amish community
the um and the baptist
sect uh they broke away at one point
from the mennonites
um both of them coming from germany
uh to this part of the world and they
live
in uh the way they're ancestors lived
um for hundreds of years so they still
work with horses
for example and that's referred to
at the at the end of the poem
an image of three horses uh attached to
apply so anyway it's called an item
again i find myself at a party
in that big windowed room overlooking
a kitchen midden alongside my wife
and a woman with whom i had once
been smitten i'd remembered her
as faith now she went by hope
lovely rita hope was saying
is a semitone higher
because the tape was speeded up
aren't we just a little too far inland
to be eating steamers
there's a case for calling a prenup a
post
nap it's the same route
to stem to stammer
they're both anabaptist sects
it goes back to some schism
our biggest problem is we're no longer
customers viewing the world through the
prism of the mine
or the steel mill this is an entirely
new mode of post-industrial
capitalism in which we ourselves
are the commodity it was with a sense of
deja vu
we watched the live stream
from beyond the window of that
amish ploy man who'd stopped
unpicking a furrow scene
to realign the harness pads
collars and hemes
of his three abreast team
the heims of course as many of you will
know the wooden
um component of the horse's
collar to two pieces of bent wood
that go around the corner
i'll read upon actually now from
the last book i published which was
called frolic and deter
and it's a little horsey poem also
and it's a poem but one of my very first
memories
in fact my first memory uh i was brought
up in
a county first few years in of my life
and connie tyrone
in northern ireland and this was just
after the second world war
of course there were still quite a few
horses
to be found partly of course because
during the war itself petrol
had been rationed and so that
the horse had made something of a
comeback
and was used for uh various
agriculture activities and general uh
general work so this is palmer
called the great horse of the world i
use the word stale
here stale it's a technical it's a term
for urinate i hope it's not too early in
the day
for you there for me to start talking
about urination
anyway the great horse of the world
the first thing i remember is being
stepped on by a horse
while it paused to stale
paying me no more heed than it would an
upset
pail of water or feed
or a comb dragged through
the coarse hair of its men
and tail the great horse of the world
stamps and champs of the bit
and lays back one ear
as i approach from the rear to hitch it
to the world coach
mindful of keeping at least
one hand on it so it knows
i'm still here and those of you who
have spent time with horses
will know that it's always a good idea
to let a horse know that you're you're
in the vicinity
um otherwise he she it or they
might uh kick you
so um i wrote a poem
um set at this time of year
it said actually on
may 20th um a few years back
20 21 years back actually right about
the time of the birth of my
son and
20 years ago for sure
you could pretty much set your clock by
the fact
that more or less almost
almost exactly on that date every year
the red knots a type of bird of course
would land on the shores of delaware bay
and as i described in the poem
they would um feed there
on the horseshoe crabs that are lumbered
up onto the bay
it's one of those wonderful
moments in nature when of course the
timing of
one event is depends very much on the
other i
i suspect that even in the 20 years that
have
passed since then that something of that
ability to you know set once clocked by
it
may have gone because as you know the
the rhythms of the world and the uh the
various
systems of the world have changed
dramatically even over those past
20 years but any case i'll i'll read
this poem it's a very
um straightforward uh poem just
a quick description of of
of um an event red knots
the day our sun is
due is the very day
the red knots are meant to touch down
on their long haul from chile
to the arctic circle
where they'll nest on the tundra within
a few
feet of where they were hatched
40 or 50 000 of them
are meant to drop in along delaware
bay they time their arrival
on these shores to coincide
with the horseshoe crabs laying their
eggs in the sand
smallish birds to begin with
the red nuts have now lost
half their weight eating the eggs of the
horseshoe crabs
is what gives them the strength to go on
40 or 50 000 of them
getting up all at once as
if for a rock
concert encore
i mentioned chile in that poem
and i hope you don't mind i'm kind of
making this up as i go along and i tend
to do that with my readings because
it keeps me present and i hope will keep
you present
too um so i published a book a few years
ago called the animals of
chile um i published a book a few years
ago
called mules and um
indeed
um when it was published in the u.s
a disgruntled customer wrote to the
publisher
and said i bought this book mules
and i i discovered that it has
absolutely nothing
to do with mules whatsoever
and i think the same might well have
been said of the
this book the animals of chile didn't
have a whole lot to do with chile
but there is a poem in which um
one of the uh the the chilean chilean
heroes bernardo o'higgins
there were two o'higgins and in chile
father and son who took who played a
huge role
in the liberation of chile
and needless to say if they're called
o'higgins they're probably a couple of
irish fellows for the most part so
anyway
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas